وهذا الموضوع هو ملف وقفه مع الحدث مع
الزميل خالد الغرابلي اهلا بك خالد ما
الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه من خلال هذا الخطاب
للرئيس بوتين طبعا نتحدث عن مستقبل هذه
الحرب التي بدات قبل نحو عام نتوقع للاسف
استمرار هذه الحرب يعني خطاب استمر لاكثر
من ساعه ونصف لم نسمع فيه ولو كلمه واحده
عن حل عن مفاوضات عن مبادرات لم يتم
الحديث على الاطلاق عن ذلك وانما كان
الحديث عن معركه وجود بالنسبه للجانب
الروسي هكذا يقدم الرئيس الروسي الامور
لشعبه يقول ان الغرب يريد القضاء على
روسيا وتدمير روسيا مره واحده والى الابد
وبالتالي الغرب بحسب رئيس الروسي
يهاجم الثقافه الروسيه القيم الروسيه
الكنيسه الروسيه امن الروس وبالتالي وجود
وكيان الدوله الروسيه والشعب الروسي
وعلينا ان نحمي انفسنا وبالتالي ماذا
تنتظرين بعد ذلك وداد من مواطن روسيا
عندما يسمع ان كل ما تربى عليه حتى اصبح
شاب مثلا من في بيته من عادات وتقاليد
وثقافه وفي الكنيسه وايضا امن اهله واسرته
مهدد من قبل الغرب هذه معركه وجود وعندما
تكون هناك معركه وجود سيقدم كل ما يمكن
للانكسار في هذه المعركه وقال الرئيس
الروسي بوضوح روسيا لن تنهزم في هذه
المعركه وعندما تتحدث يتحدث رئيس دوله
نوويه عن ان بلاده لن تنهزم في هذه
المعركه عسكريا نفهم من ذلك انه السلاح
النووي سيكون هو الضامن في النهايه لضمان
انتصار روسيا في هذه المعركه التي لم يسمح
فيها ابدا بالهزيمه ومن هنا نفهم
ان هذه المعركه ستطول وكل ما تحدث عنه بعد
ذلك الرئيس الروسي
كان نوع من اعداد الوطن الروسي لاستمرار
هذه المعركه من خلال الحديث عن تطوير
القوات المسلحه تطوير القدرات النوويه
تحديث المجتمع الروسي بشكل عام اذا روسيا
تعتبر ما يحدث في اوكرانيا هي مجرد ساحه
لمعركه اكبر لحرب اكبر ان اردت مع الغرب
الغرب الذي يريد القضاء على روسيا وروسيا
تريد ان تبقى في العالم كدوله عظمى جاء
بعد هذا الخطاب لبوتين هذا تصريح
عن تعليم او اعلان تعليق المشاركه الروسيه
في معاناه نيو ستار لنزع السلاح النووي
كيف يمكن تفسير ذلك
الملاحظه ان رئيس روسيا كان حريصه على
تحديد انه لا يعني الانسحاب وانما تعليق
الفرق طبعا كبير التعليق يمكن العوده او
تراجع عنه اذا توفرت الشروط المناسبه لكن
في النهايه ماذا يعني ذلك
مع انتهاء الحرب البارده الجانبان
الامريكي والروسي وقع العديد من
الاتفاقيات للحد من القدرات النوويه
للبلدين من خلال الحد من كميه السلاح
النووي وايضا الاسلحه التي تحمل هذا
السلاح النووي لضرب العدو وبالتالي يتم
تحديد مخاطر احتمال مواجهه نوويه بين
الجانبين لكن مع مرور الوقت مرور السنوات
وتوتر العلاقات انتهت الاتفاقيه كل
الاتفاقيات تقريبا لسبب او لاخر باستثناء
اتفاقيه واحده هي معهد الحد من الاسلحه
الهجوميه هذه هذه التي نتحدث عنها وهي
معنيه بالصواريخ بعيده المدى العبر
القرارات الخضراء على حمل رؤوس نوويه
اليوم تعلن روسيا تعليق المشاركه في هذه
الاتفاقيه هذا يعني ان ببساطه هذا فتح
الباب لنوع من صباغ تسلح نووي في المرحله
المقبله بين الطرفين ومخاطر مواجهه هذا
لان روسيا تنظر الى ما يحدث الان ليس مجرد
حرب بالنسبه روسيا هي عمليه عسكريه لكن هي
في النهايه لا يقتصر الامر عما يحدث في
اوكرانيا انما هي معركه نكون على هذه
الخارطه على مستوى العالم او لا نكون
وعندما نتحدث عن بقاء او عدم بقاء هو يقصد
المواجهه مع الغرب الذي يستهدف روسيا
وبالتالي من اجل التصدي لهذا الهجوم
الغربي كما يقدمه الرئيس الروسي لابد ان
تكون روسيا قويه ومن الادوات التي تسمح
لها ان تكون قويه هو الاستمرار ان اردت في
الحفاظ على قوه وما يقوله اليوم هو يفتح
الباب كما قلت لنوع من سباق التسلح النووي
وهذا يعني ان العالم غدا ربما يكون اقل
امنا طيب خالد يعني نحن مقبلون على هذا
الخطاب ايضا من بولندا لرئيس الامريكيه ما
الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه على ضوء هذه
التصريحات وهذا الخطاب لبوتين من الجانب
الاخر اقصد الجانب الامريكي الجانب
الامريكي يعني من خلال زياده بيض لبولندا
في الغالب هو لحشد الحلفاء لكن الرساله
الاساسيه التي يتوقع ان تعاد مره اخرى في
بولندا في وارسو هي ما سمعنها بالامس
ان
الولايات المتحده ووجود الولايات المتحده
والحلفاء مع اكياف هو الذي منع سقوط كييف
عندما توجهت الدبابات والصواريخ والطائرات
الروسيه للهجوم على كيف وهي التي ستبقى
الولايات المتحده والحلفاء او الحلفاء
سيبقون مع كيف طالما استدعى الامر ذلك هذا
ايضا معناه ان المرحله المقبله ستكون
استمرار لهذه الحرب واهم ما يمكن ان يقال
هي ان يخرج هذه الرساله من الولايات
المتحده لان الولايات المتحده هي اهم ما
نح مالي لاوكرانيا الولايات المتحده هي
اهم دوله تقدم احدث الاسلحه لاوكرانيا ليس
فقط بما تقدمه هي بشكل مباشر بل الحلفاء
لا يجرؤون على تقديم مساعدات عسكريه من
نوعيه معينه لاوكرانيا الا بعد موافقه
الولايات المتحده حتى يضمنوا حمايه
الولايات المتحده لان هذه الاسلحه من
الممكن ان تغضب روسيا ويكون هناك رد فعل
روسي لكن عندما يكون هناك الضمانه
الامريكيه وهناك حمايه امريكيه اذا
الولايات المتحده من خلال تقديم الاموال
وتقديم السلاح بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر
تقديم التدريبات العسكريه الان يتم اعداد
الاوكرانيين لمعركه الشتاء من خلال
التدريب المشاه والاسلحه الجديده والتنسيق
بين الاسلحه المختلفه ليكون اكثر فاعليه
على الارض في معركه الربيع المقبل من خلال
تقديم المعلومات الاستخباراتيه صور
الاقمار الاصطناعيه الولايات المتحده هي
العمود الفقري الداعم لاوكرانيا في هذه
الحرب ومن المهم بالنسبه لاوكرانيا ان
تسمع الان هذه الرساله من بايدن لكن
السؤال الكبير ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث اذا
خرجت الانتخابات الامريكيه المقبله في
نوفمبر من العام المقبل برئيس جديد غير
بايدن برئيس من الجمهوريين لا يرى ان من
مصلحه الولايات المتحده انفاق كل هذه
المليارات من اجل دوله بعيده جغرافيا عن
الولايات المتحده سمعنا الكثير من انتقدات
الجمهوريه الان لهذه الدوله التي لهذه
الجوله التي يقوم بها بايدن ما الذي يمكن
ان يحدث ان جاء رئيس جمهوري لا يقدم كل
هذا الدعم المالي كل هذه الاسلحه كل هذه
الحمايه للحلفاء لكي يساعدوا اوكرانيا
ليبقي هذا التحالف الدولي
مع اوكرانيا حتى تستطيع ان تحدث نتيجه
ملموسه على الارض هذا معناه ان كل مستقبل
هذا الحرب قد يتغير ومن هنا عامل الوقت
يبدو في مصلحه روسيا لان روسيا الان تجند
شعبها ان اردت على انه في معركه بقاء وانا
الغاب يريد القضاء عليهم وهذه فرصتهم لكي
يبقوا نكون او لا نكون باختصار اما
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده فهي تصابق الزمن
لتحقيق نوع من الانتصار على الارض قبل
نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله ان كل
شيء من الممكن ان يتغير وتدخل الامور في
نوع من الحرب الجامده التي استمرارها يعني
استنزاف لقدرات حلف الاطلسي وطبعا الدول
المشاركه فيه وبدون نتيجه سياسيه حاسمه
للوضع جزيلا شكرا لك خالد الغراب